with transformation in hand with
applications henry located on board
member state the chap emergency places places
border security that is one of our
expectations that we have for the european council
that borders have to be
guarded and that
honesty
also means saying no to borders  when people without a
visa and a refugee
come underground the six commercial
international
it comes from alliance data systems putin
suffers is from the yucatán in front of the atlantis
seven member states the idea of ​​the
social union is buried
that is clear to me after what
i have read
here  is not a compromise that has been
offered, but that is the kneeling
before the model in the
line of demands from mr cameron,
so he is trying to exert
an incredibly large influence
on the european decision-making process for great britain, including through veto rights
, and
at the same time he wants maximum  exceptions
for s  i am further guaranteed
ambitions about it youth jury with
parliamentarians and double bass transport
parliament winterberg is one of the
bsi as well as mental